[Music]
so what do you want to sing tonight I
brought this just today we didn't invite
you guys to sing we invited you to watch
I'll kiss Cuse me I just thought you
guys are so busy with your awesome jobs
and amazing lives I am actually you're
so bright and shiny still pretty they
look like they was all breastfed either
the USO puts on this performance to
support the troops in Europe one last
show together who is with me oh yeah
[Music]
welcome to Spain fellas so this is the
first base will we be going a second
base with you guys that's a note from me
so on the tour we've got three bands you
guys are seeing other people's songs
right like a cover band they're trying
to intimidate us let's just go to a reef
off
we like to keep it oral
and yeah we're that everybody is better
at the one thing that we do then then we
are at that thing alright ladies pick up
your test we're going to show them that
we are not a joke my record label wants
to sign one of the bands but we don't
want the bends we want you what I did
not see this coming
family we support each other we like
sisters all great
he is Aubry isn't it I can't I'm part of
a group Becca it's a big opportunity for
you
[Applause]
[Music]
bye-bye Bela's it really does feel like
a bi job Becca what are you doing don't
ya if you cry I'm gonna cry don't make
that face I'm not doing it don't make
that face
[Music]
you